i think
so it's funny because i feel like ali
sadiq has had these like career moments
a little bit
whereas like the last time he blew was
mexican on boots
and when you go watch mexican on boots
and you listen to that story
everything about that story is so
detailed
like it's got so much detail
to it
and the details that he tells you
puts you literally in the position of
where he was
as he's going through all of this and
that's why he's so prolific his style of
bringing you in
and that's the other thing about allah
sadiq
very different than earthquake yes ali
takes his ever loving time yep you are
not going to rush anything he says
and i love that it's such a comfort
level just like i think in watching him
in atlanta
as he sits down on this chair
it's about 15 seconds
for him to say
anything
and he's just him getting comfortable
in the chair just like just a little bit
of wiggle just like
you mean yeah he's like and then like
his first words away
hey
how y'all doing
yeah he did that in his comedy central
special too
and then he just goes into this but like
just goes into the store and it's like
yo just that level of just like
i'ma do me
is so
like it's
it's so incredibly talent it's such a
different level of talent
and it also is
not just like the details he uses but
then in this special it's such a good
presentation of just
he says the details but then like he
said like fighting the dope fiends he's
like physically fighting the dope fiends
like he is showing you
what he's talking about not only with
his words where you paint the picture
but physically as well which is like two
different as we break down these
specials you know we look at like the
writing and the personal aspect of it
but also the performing aspect of it to
where he is like yeah he sits down
but he can be just as big on stage like
as as he is sitting down he can bring it
up physically moving around the stage i
think even that that part of it the fact
that he sits down moves and then goes
back and sits down
shows you the level of comfort that he
is with his story like he's like this is
a sit down portion of the story nope
this is let me get up and show you
portion of the story
and what i like about that is that
you could tell that like
he is what you think
when you think like a funny family
member
it's the embodiment of ali sadiq ali
siddique is that funny family member or
like that old uncle that you've got that
be telling just wild stories yeah
he's literally the embodiment of
every uncle that everyone has that you
know has been through some [ __ ] you know
he's seen some stuff
right like he's got like one leg like
he's got just stories or he's got like
you know like a scar you're like where'd
you get that guy let me tell you the
story next thing you know you're sitting
down for another 30 minutes as your
uncle tells you the story but just
uh somebody said he's definitely bill
cosby yes he's like bill cosby is titus
that are very much but
he does storytelling in today's day
like nobody else and it's so different
than
what you think comedy is going because
comedy is so like
i would say comedy is very much like
short
uh what's the word
like attention span yeah and it's like
it's like mark norman sam morrell
i mean even earthquake who
his special inspired this entire show we
do now and we're actually gonna review
ali's special on the earthquake scale
that we started last week
but earthquake is boom boom boom boom
boom boom but ali is
smooth it's like jazz
but it hays off the pops the lap
a few times i was like oh well that's a
different laugh
you know what i mean you're like that is
a house laugh like
he is murdering but on his pace
yeah
yeah yeah there were
i counted like
there were maybe like
eight to ten moments
where
even the crowd couldn't stop themselves
like they were laughing and he had to
like wait for them to finish laughing
you don't say like you're like like
because he didn't like i don't think he
even realized how funny the thing was
because they still laughed even after
like it died down because it was that
good of a joke you know i'm saying it
was like yeah or his facial expression
or he would get a laugh just on a look
you know yeah
which i took a screenshot of this facial
expression i mean this thing just killed
me
that's that's quintessential ali
siddique right there
[Music]
it's so good but yeah let's get into the
numbers i'm sorry i cut off your
analysis there
oh somebody said what's written on the
wall uh it's intentional present
grateful and laugh
it's just the way that i think about my
days i just try to be intentional try to
be present try to be grateful and then
laugh at it but yeah that's what's on my
wall um
so the numbers
uh
it's an hour the special itself is an
hour 20 minutes
but the end of it he actually does a
little bit like it's almost like a
blooper reel or just like another
version of a
part of the set so it's actually kind of
cool just to watch a different version
of that um so the entire special is an
hour 15 minutes so it's 75 minutes long
and he had 405 laughs
and at that pace that's five and a half
laps a minute
now
that five and a half laps a minute at
his pace
it's not like he's getting laughs really
per minute
they're like
eight to ten spots where this dude
literally gets laughs like every single
word that comes out of his mouth like it
was like it was just like bam bam bam
bam big pop
again bam bam bam like
th the laughs are staggered around in
the special but they're staggered in the
right places it was incredible to watch
like
like
what i what i really like about it is he
told you what was about to happen
and then showed you
and then you still laughed at it
yeah
and when we talk about laughs some of
these are long laughs too this isn't
like
it's like
yeah they're like tidal waves of
laughter
waves of life um
and one of my favorite things
about this
is
the first three sentences of the special
literally set you up for the entire show
um
yes
i mean it was so good it was just like
it's almost like it was like a
scientific research it was just like i'm
gonna tell you this thing
and it's gonna affect everything else
that i say from here on out
but just what it was itself was just a
good observation
about his own like
i just recognized this thing about what
happened in my life
and i'ma tell you a little bit about it
and how i got there and then
hour 15 into
the story it was so well done
yeah it's like you said before maybe
before the show is like you can see the
you can see the movie like this is
literally like it's like a movie that
he's telling us in like a three-act
structure
that is hilarious
ha
hilarious yeah yeah i mean
like so the numbers you said it was
basically an hour 20 and he was it's an
hour 13 minutes hour
the special says it's about 20 but
there's about five minutes in the
beginning at the end sorry right that's
like a repeat of another story right
yeah that's true yeah after the credits
yeah
it's almost like after the credits like
the marvel thing to do um
but yeah 405 laughs uh
within that whole thing and
uh i counted the pops there were about
nine pops
of just huge
laughs like just big
like i mean what i would think to be
applause breaks but just where
he had to like stop before going on
because it was just that well
executed of jokes
but yeah yeah house laughs as we call it
in the biz
you'll get there young gun you'll get
there we call those house laughs
i think my favorite part about this
special is how specific
everything was
he left no detail unturned
and what i like about ali siddique is
like he's also not afraid to put names
to everything that's what i liked about
that mexican with boots i still remember
anybody know cece you know cece
it's like this is specifically
like
cece is the guy that you go call who's
got the knife in jail like
i remember that like vividly of how
funny
just but like it's that style but yeah
the specificity that he uses in his
storytelling is magical and he says in
the special that he uses real names
because all of these are true stories
so he's like you can ask them this he's
like all this is true and that's how
he's able to use real names
oh that's so good
so
this is the moment everyone's been
waiting on now
this is it's time
to do
what is the on the earthquake scale on
the earthquake scale i mean one out of
five earthquakes
on the earthquake scale this is a
certified
five not five earthquakes
five out of five earthquakes yes this
question
is
like legitimately the definition this is
the definition for any comic who's like
oh i'm a storyteller yes this is the
storyteller special if you ever be like
oh i'm a storyteller i tell long stories
i don't have any jokes or i can't write
all these jokes for the life story
yeah
watch this special
yep and then yeah
freestyle of this special
that's yeah
i i couldn't agree more you know uh we
started this last week with kat williams
special and you and i had different
ratings uh but this one you know i i
couldn't agree more it's i think it's i
think it's five out of five a hundred
percent and
i i try to go into these reviews
unbiased you know i want to watch it as
a working professional comedian
i'm i'm a fan of cat williams last week
you know and i i gave him three out of
five earthquakes you know so
i i like to be subjective about these
separating the kind of me being a fan of
this comic from the work
this
is another level like it it's it's up
there with the earthquake special like
earthquakes is like 35 minutes we said
you know his boom boom boom boom this
one hour 15
and it it does not disappoint there's no
lulls wow
it's at ali sadiq's pace yes right yeah
his earthquake just is a fast-paced
comedian yeah right so he's going to
give you man
it's like a boxing match kind of thing
yeah
it's an earthquake it's a natural
disaster it's like this is a sit down
oh we about to have a good time like
like
i watch i watched a special three times
to your point
first of all first one was just like
just let me watch it just as a casual
fan
second was i watched it as a comedian
like i try to find the jokes i try to
find where certain things were if i
could see things coming and then i
watched it the third time like
as a specialist i was like i got like
deep into like the joke structure
it didn't disappoint even the third time
through i was laughing at the same stuff
all the way through because of how
detailed
and just organic all his stories were it
was so good such a good start it's it's
it's a comedy it's a masterpiece in my
opinion it's someone who's been doing
comedy
at a high level for a long time
it's i mean it's kind of like earthquake
where earthquakes had some things
but that chappelle special that he
produced like kind of put him on the map
for a lot of people i think i hope this
special does the same overnight success
exactly
exactly
exactly so five out of five earthquakes
yeah for mr ali sadiq without a doubt
like
originality
no one's ever going to be able to tell
that story
the stage presence was like
magical he didn't
he moved all over the place like he's
not even like he's not like a like a
sebastian where he's just like arms or
anything like that
he slowed it down but then
like the fighting scenes and like yeah
my favorite line
was when he when he was talking about
the guy who threw him in the dumpster
and he goes and he goes to the other guy
he was like yeah and you threw me in a
dumpster too
and that i love
i love it when comics aren't afraid to
be silly you know ali is a scary dude
and if anyone has seen my interviews
with him
in both interviews i've done with ali
there have been both moments where i've
been like you're scaring me because like
i'm alone in a hotel room with this guy
and i'm like he could literally kill me
right now and not even think twice about
it and that that's it like there's
they don't use
he has a presence about him that is so
like assured yes someone
who doesn't take any [ __ ] like part of
my french but like he's just not he's
not a guy to be messed with like
he is so but he's also so comfortable
with himself and who he is
but also like
at the core of it
he's just like a regular everyday dude
that's been through some [ __ ] that loves
telling these stories yeah
and i also love the fact that he's also
very much like
one of those people is like no just do
what you want to do
just do you more than anything else
because he was i mean i remember in that
interview that you did he was like man i
don't care about last per minute
he'd hate that we have the number on
this yeah he really would he really
would and he he goes in on like he's a
purist when it comes to comedy like he
talks about in the in the podcast about
like if he's like if you have a sitcom i
guarantee your stand-up sucks like he he
says
stuff like that where he's like he's a
purist funny first
like in a very real way of coming from a
real place so yeah five out of five
comics it's a must watch
and um for people that have seen it i'd
love to see
what maybe what your rating would be out
of five for the people that are watching
this right now we both gave it five out
of five but we'd love to see your
opinion and
what's um
five out of five so
there it is
there it is five out of five earthquakes
the first of its kind
we have not given a five out of five
earthquakes yet but
this is the first
so
yeah i agree